you know aaron rodgers uh i see a bear  out there  it leads me to a question october 17th  packers bears any idea who's going to be  there anybody who's going to be  quarterbacking in the number 12 jersey  yeah i don't know b.a let's see  how about we how about september 12th  then how will you go for that one  what's that one that would be the opener  against the saints  oh all cheesers resort rejoice yeah i  don't know ba what's he okay i know  you're a milwaukee guy  i know aaron everybody is on their toes  they want to know man they want to know  yeah but i mean i'm just having a good  time out here with tom i'm trying to  talk to him about it  he's going to keep playing or not you  know  hey aaron we go way back you can just  tell me i'll keep it a secret  i promise i will not put it anywhere  charles i'll tell you this  week in tahoe and you can you can  you can leak it okay i got you  dinner's on me that'll be a first